a bomb kid my name is sin a cruel one my  friends call me Harris I live in krabi  province in Thailand on the island of  Koh plum  Paul Megan Coleman my father drives a  motorcycle taxi and my mother is a  housewife son may have been mayor  bang-up realizable I spend time feeding  our animals the geese ducks and chickens  I enjoy that  well not deep he'll throw so much  garbage onto the beach that bothers me  because the ocean should be clean it's a  global problem nowadays but may I even  get good but um yeah I tally got muscle  I'm not happy when I walk along the  beach because it's just so full of  garbage people by God lemon them new  Nigel hub Cindy Tom upon me I'm happy  when I'm inventing something useful  right now I'm making flower pots out of  coconuts you can hang them up been  banged up my way now bon  you